here's an easy way that you can get more
money from every single customer that
you sign up whenever you sign them up
and you're getting their credit card ask
them for a second form of payment and
you can waive a credit card fee that you
would normally charge if they add a
second one and you're like this is just
because it decreases our admin cost and
God forbid you get your identity stolen
we don't have to interrupt your service
when you do it that way you already have
the first card you ask for the second it
gives them a discount gives you a second
form of payment so that when that
decline does happen you have a second
one that you can hit immediately